How many of you have ever had an idea for business
or a product,
but you were just too scared to go for it?
Cause starting your own company is not easy.
It's the most intimidating thing.
And this year has been especially not incentivizing
and tough on small businesses.
And that's why our show loves highlighting them.
So now it's time for another edition of;
Small Business Challenge!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
Oh! Thank you.
Okay. In this challenge, two entrepreneurs face off
to win a prize package that will help take their company
to the next level.
Today we have two companies
and they both are already featured
on our little book of small businesses.
Take a look.
(upbeat music continuing)
Hi, I'm Jasmine. This is Justin.
We're husband and wife team
and the owners and co-founders of Morning Joy Co.
At Morning Joy Co.,
we make laser engraved recipe cutting boards.
You can send an old family recipe
and we'll engrave the exact handwriting on a cutting board.
We started our business in April, 2020
and almost immediately felt like we were onto something.
We started hearing feedback from our customers,
that our products were special
and over and over again, we hear the same story.
These are perfect gifts to preserve cherished memories.
Our dream is to keep growing the business.
We want to expand our products
create a website and invest in upgraded equipment.
Thank you Drew, and to all of you,
for supporting small businesses like ours.
We're so excited for what's to come.
Hi, I'm Tamara owner and founder
of Queen Bee Jelly Modern Fabrics.
Queen Bee Jelly Modern Fabrics, is an online fabric boutique
specializing in Ankara.
Which is an African fabric.
Because the fabric is so beautiful,
I would love to see it in hotels, used for upholstery's,
the headboards, and draperies, pillows,
or even in schools.
So I realize my purpose is to inspire others.
And that's what I built Queen Bee Jelly off of.
(audience clapping)
All right. To get this started.
I'm so excited.
I want to welcome my co-judge.
He is a businessman, investor, author, motivational speaker
and one of the stars of ABC's Shark Tank.
Its my favorite show!
Please welcome Damon John.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
(Drew laughing)
(audience cheering)
Oh my goodness.
I can't believe I'm sitting here.
Thank you for coming.
As you can see,
we haven't had that many people come out.
I looked that way.
I didn't know where you weren't coming from
Its amazing. This is the first time I've been out.
Okay. I am the biggest Shark Tank fan.
I'm sure you hear that all the time.
I can't hear it enough. We really appreciate it.
Well, it's just such a genius show
for those who love inventions, for those who love business,
and I am obsessed with business.
Speaking of business, I mean, your company FUBU has
over 6 billion with a B in sales.
and you started out in your mother's house...
Yeah.
In Queens and then turned it into a global empire.
I can't think of anyone to talk about
building a business with.
Yeah, it was tough, but thank God.
And I think that's what everybody loves about Shark Tank.
They see everyday people that
just get up off the couch and they make it happen.
Well, I like hearing you say that.
Cause we talked about some of the fear that goes
into taking that leap of faith,
Sure
You know, giving up security, going for the dream.
It's terrifying
and you meet budding entrepreneurs every single day
in the 12 seasons that you've done.
You've made over 80 deals.
And for this segment I want to get right
to what are you looking for in pitches?
Which I'm just excited as a viewer also to know.
Well, you know what, I'm generally looking for the fact
that they have, they have what we call a proof of concept.
They've sold to somebody.
It doesn't have to be a massive amount.
And often because my money personally,
and you know today is not necessarily the same situation.
I look to see if I like the person.
In business whether you are trying to
apply for a job with somebody or
whether you're trying to get an investment
people would just have to like you.
They wanna know that they can sit next to you forever.
So are you ready today for the small business challenge?
I am. I'm ready.
Okay. I can't, I'm freaking out. All right.
Let's meet our entrepreneurs.
Please welcome Justin and Jasmine, all rad.
The owners of Morning Joy Co.
(audience clapping)
Oh my God! Hey?
Hey!
Hey guys?
love your products.
Love featuring you on our small business guide.
Thank you for joining and Tamara Walker
the owner of Queen Bee Jelly. Hey?
(audience clapping and cheering)
I'm such a fan of both of your businesses.
I can't believe I'm getting to do this with Damon.
Would you guys like to know what you're competing for today?
Yes! Oh my gosh.
Yes!
All right. Lets take a look.
(upbeat music continuing)
The winner of today's small business challenge.
We'll receive a marketing package, which includes a feature
on the homepage of our show's website.
A consultation with award-winning PR executive
Susan Magreeno.
Who's worked with clients such as Martha Stuart
Cuisine Art, Virgin Atlantic and Coach.
And to top it off;
today's winner will receive $10,000 from bill.com.
The leading payment software company.
And the runner up won't go home empty handed.
They will also receive $1,000.
(audience clapping)
Thank you guys. Really.
We're so excited to do this with you.
And are you ready?
First up, Justin and Jasmine, what is your pitch?
Why should you win?
Hi, I'm Jasmine. This is Justin.
We are the owners and co-founders of Morning Joy Co.
We make custom engraved, cutting boards.
Most popularly we engrave original
handwritten recipes as keepsakes.
We started our business after trying to start our family
and finding out we were unable to have biological children.
We still wanted to create a legacy
and make something beautiful together.
And so Morning Joy Co. was born.
What makes us unique is our personalized
customer experience, with step-by-step communication
from first draft to final product.
It creates a personal connection with each
of our customers, which has provided us
1400 sales and over 400 reviews
in the last year of starting our business.
Every single review has been five-star.
We also plan to expand our products
and invest in better equipment.
And if we win this amazing competition
we hope to be able to reach closer to our goals.
Drew and Damon, we just wanted to say thank you so much
Thank you.
For this opportunity.
I'm just honored to do it with everyone here in this room.
And Damon, I want to throw it to you.
Do you have a question for Justin and Jasmine?
Yes. So, so I love hearing about the reviews.
If there's 400 reviews, did you have say you had 1400 sales?
Yeah, we started our business on April 4th and...
Last year
Yeah. Last year to the date.
Over 1400 sales. Yeah in total.
Units right?
More units. Some people will order, make an order.
We've had as much as 11 boards on a single order, so.
Right.
Have you sold to any retailers at all?
[Justin And Jasmine] No.
Okay. Perfect. Yeah.
Okay.
(upbeat music)